Kanye West goes off on a Twitter tirade
attacking his wife and his family and
you know this is just the latest in a
series of bizarre outbursts that are
raising real concern about his mental
health
if you guys want these crazy ideas
there's a chance it might come from a
crazy person I've seen him go through
you might say things that might get
misinterpreted but I always know his
heart
Kim is completely devastated that's what
a source tells ET after Kanye dropped 23
tweets in 94 minutes last night then
deleted most of them but don't take me
the wrong way Kim tried to bring a
doctor to lock me up the 43 year old
rapper wrote he also posted a picture of
his kids and tweeted West children will
never do Playboy referring to Kim's
famous photoshoot with the mag posts
he tells Kris Jenner you are not allowed
around my children Kris and Kim call me
now I'm at the ranch come and get me and
everybody knows the movie get out is
about me now you're in a second place
Kanye ended his rant saying I'm a focus
on the music now he has a new album
dropping Friday Keeping Up with the
Kardashians is also currently filming
most recently with Kourtney and Kendall
in Malibu
we're told Kim's trying to get Kanye
help for his recent bipolar episode but
he's refused it hashtag pray for yay is
trending you look at your daughter you
look at your wife and how is that
fulfilled your life
it's given me a whole perspective an
understanding of what to work for what
to live for but Kanye has let one person
come to his aid dave chappelle who has
his own history with mental health he
flew out to Kanye's wyoming ranch this
morning but as Kanye continues his run
for president what will it take to get
him the help he apparently needs
stress is a precipitator of mental
conditions and so right now Kanye's got
a lot of amazing things that are
happening you know his new album is
about to drop he's working on getting in
the presidential race and those things
obviously for Kanye could be very
positive things but it's also a ton of
stress I've only been diagnosed for two
years last year Kim said they reached a
pretty good place with Kanye's mental
health telling Vogue right now
everything is really calm but we can
definitely feel episodes coming and we
know how to handle them Kim added that
traveling a lot can be a trigger
sometimes it's really difficult for the
families to get through to the
individual if they're not listening when
you're bipolar if you don't take
medication every day to keep you at a
certain state you have a potential to
wrap-up and it could take you to a point
where you can even end up in a hospital
and you start acting erratic that's
apparently what happened in 2016
[Music]
after this paranoid concert rant Kanye
canceled the rest of his tour in a few
hours later his doctor called 9-1-1 I'm
actually one of his doctors I'm just
calling for my cell phone he's
definitely gonna need to be hospitalized
I wouldn't just be the police by itself
let him get any any weapon a source told
et Kayne was hospitalized for nine days
at UCLA Medical Center
Kanye cited as factors the stress of his
workload a past addiction to opioid
medication and Kim's robbery in Paris he
feeling like helpless he feeling like
what can you do it I went on that trip
to protect her realize is that you know
for himself for his family for his kids
and for his career that was really all
about managing his life in a way that's
more balanced so that he doesn't have
resurgence is a symptoms as much
[Music]